herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live
der polizei ist es gelungen einen der
welt eine der weltweit größten
kinderpornografie plattformen zu
zerschlagen die darknet plattform beust
soll 400.000 accounts 400.000 mitglieder
gehabt haben 400.000 menschen die sich
am anblick sexuell missbrauchter kinder
offenbar ergötzt haben unter den
geteilten bildern und videos hätten sich
auch aufnahmen zitat schwersten
sexuellen missbrauchs von kleinkindern
befunden so die behörden heute die
politik feiert das ganze als großen
erfolg hessens justiz ministerin sagt
ein fantastischer ermittlungserfolg bei
der bekämpfung von sexualisierter gewalt
gegen kinder und jugendliche und
bundesinnenminister seehofer sagt wer
sich an den schwächsten vergeht ist
nirgendwo sicher dass alles also ein
großer erfolg oder taucht vielleicht
morgen schon die nächste große plattform
auf wie groß ist dieser erfolg also
einzuschätzen und vor allen dingen wie
können wir unsere kinder schützen was
können wir tun darüber wollen wir mit
zwei experten sprechen zum einen doktor
thomas gabriel rüdiger er ist cyber
kriminologen und experte für
kinderpornografie am institut für
polizei wissenschaften der polizei des
landes brandenburg ich grüße sie ganz
herzlich und zum anderen wollen wir
sprechen mit astrid berlin helsinki von
der world childhood foundation auch mit
ihr werden wir vor allen dingen dann
über die frage sprechen wie wir die
kinder schützen können gemeinsam wollen
wir uns aber erst einmal anschauen was
die informationen des heutigen tages
sind was bekannt geworden ist welcher
ring zerschlagen worden ist
beust und funktionierte wie ein
marktplatz verborgen im anonymen darknet
die gehandelte ware bilder und videos
von kindern zumeist jungen darunter
zahlreiche darstellungen schwersten
sexuellen missbrauchs mit mehr als
400.000 mitgliedern gehörte die
plattform zu den größten drei deutsche
männer im alter von 40 bis 58 jahren
sollen die hauptverantwortlichen sein
bei drei der beschuldigten besteht der
dringende tatverdacht als
administratoren auf beuys horn tätig
gewesen zu sein
in dieser funktion sollen sie die
plattform ins leben gerufen haben sollen
die infrastruktur zur verfügung gestellt
haben den server gewartet haben sollen
sich um die mitgliederbetreuung
gekümmert haben ein weiterer 64 jahre
alter mann soll als einer der aktivsten
nutzer allein über 3.500 beiträge
gepostet haben alle befinden sich
zurzeit in u-haft einer der verdächtigen
wurde in paraguay festgenommen
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer
äußerte sich zufrieden dieser
ermittlungserfolg hat eine klare
botschaft wer sich an den schwächsten
vergeht es nirgendwo sicher wir ziehen
die täter zur rechenschaft und tun das
menschenmögliche um kinder vor so
widerwärtigen verbrechen zu schützen
die ermittler haben unmengen an daten
sichergestellt die jetzt ausgewertet
werden müssen die sachen hoch aber es
wird auch vieles bekanntes material
natürlich getauscht und die kriminelle
szene sind die sammler die versuchen
möglichst viel bildmaterial zu bekommen
sich gegenseitig auch anzustarren was
nur ein großer ermittlungserfolg die
plattform boston wurde abgeschaltet aber
sie war nur eine von vielen
herr doktor rüdiger frage an sie den
cyberkriminellen der sich bestens mit
den dingen auskennt ist das jetzt heute
ein riesenerfolg eine plattform
zerschlagen mit 400.000 mitgliedern oder
wird es morgen dafür einfach zwei neue
geben also ein erfolg ist jeder schlag
gegen so eine plattform das muss man
klar sagen aber man braucht sich jetzt
auch nicht der illusion hin setzen dass
man damit irgendwie das phänomen
hinreichend bekämpft werden
sehen sie wie sich schon zu recht gesagt
haben aus so einer plattform kommen neue
spuren dann kommen neue plattform dazu
reden wir jetzt über das datennetz viel
spielt sich auch in den sozialen medien
im web also für alle zugänglichen
bereich des internets auf und man muss
sich auch glaube ich der illusion sollte
man sich nicht hingeben dass man jetzt
hier gegen diese 400.000 offenbar
vorhandenen nutzer irgendwie etwas groß
machen kann man nimmt sich jetzt die
köpfe zu recht ob die sowas betreiben
und da finde ich kann man noch mal die
frage stellen warum in den letzten
sachen das eigentlich immer deutsche
gewesen sind oder sehr viele deutsche
mit eine rolle gespielt haben
ob die zum einen zu geringen
strafverfolgungs druck gespürt haben
aber die 400.000 also das muss man sich
mal zur vorstellung nehmen das sind mehr
täter die sich dort angemeldet haben als
wir im letzten jahr in der polizeilichen
kriminalstatistik überhaupt cyber
delikte zur anzeige bekommen haben also
alle formen von beleidigung bis zu
kindesmissbrauch
da hatten wir 320.000 anzeigen und hier
sind allein 400.000 täter wollte man
sieht die vernetzung wie die immer
weniger sich landesgrenzen kümmern und
wir agieren noch sehr stark national
strukturiert hier funktioniert es
bereits mit kooperation aber wir müssen
eigentlich ernsthaft sagen dass wir
einen globalen digitalen raum raubten
die täter sexuelle missbrauch in allen
formen betreiben in massen betreiben und
wo es zu einer art normalität eine art
omnipräsent gekommen ist und die müssen
wir mit einer echten ressourcen
verlagerung machen denn auch dazu gehört
es dass man danach diese täter ausfindig
machen die sich dort mit anmelden
trotzdem noch mal klar sagen jeder
schlag ist ein guter aber es ist nur die
spitze vom eisberg
jetzt sind sie ja eben kriminologe und
kennen die arbeit ist das jetzt
sozusagen einen zufallsfund ein
zufallstreffer
oder ist das jetzt akribischer arbeit
und kann man davon ausgehen da hat man
jetzt gezielt gearbeitet und mit der
gleichen ermittlerinnen methode wird man
jetzt in zukunft auch noch weitere
netzer in der form zerschlagen können
also einfach sagen ich kenne jetzt nicht
wie hier konkret vorgegangen wurde
typisch ist es schon dass es mit
klassischen kriminalistischen
ermittlungsmethoden funktioniert also
es ist immer so dass man irgendwie den
zugang zu dieser plattform bekommt
deswegen wurde ja zb auch das für die
keuschheitsprobe also dass man selber
kinderpornografische medien anbieten
konnte um eine solche plattform zu
kommen das wurde ja reformiert um dort
zugang dazu bekommen zu können
dieser methode muss man sagen bei
400.000 nutzern muss man auch ganz
ehrlich sagen da werden die
zugangshürden auch nicht so groß sein
weil es haben ja 400.000 menschen
offenbar nutzer und selbst wenn es nur
zehn prozent werden wir als 40.000 aber
die müssen ja relativ einfachen zugang
bekommen haben dazu und es deutet alles
immer wieder darauf hin dass die täter
sehr wenig angst vor strafverfolgung
haben weil ansonsten würde kaum einer
eigentlich so offen vorgehen oder das
könnte auch sein dass in den ländern wo
die täter alle sitzen es vielleicht
nicht in derselben form strafbar ist wie
bei uns was zum beispiel die frage
ausrüstung wenn ich war ein globales
strafrecht gegen solche phänomene
diskutieren sollten da sind wir so ein
bisschen bei dem punkt hier schreibt ein
user ever game player über youtube wenn
die polizei was dagegen tun will dann
müsste sie einfach was im dark mit tun
und zwar im dark match viel aktiver sein
das ist dann auch die gleiche frage was
kann man denn irgendwie tun in
australien ist die polizei clever mit
avataren lockt sie etc dann kommt schon
hier wieder die frage kann man das hier
überhaupt machen
am ende muss ich sagen das sind genau
solche fragen die ich mir auch stelle
man muss aber ein zu wissen ich glaube
dass zum beispiel die polizeipräsenz im
darknet insgesamt wesentlich höher ist
als den gesamten claire wird weil
nämlich gerade solche spektakulären
einsätze dort interessant sind und man
darf halt das gesamte klier wird nicht
außen vor lassen
die sozialen medien wie viel über
messenger laufen wie viel zum beispiel
auch bin ja auch immer der sich seine
dissertation cyber grooming geschrieben
hat also wie sexualtäter in netz an
kinder heran gekommen nicht nur die
bilder austauschen und das passiert
offen ganz täglich in den sozialen
medien und zwar grenzüberschreitend und
da muss man ehrlich sagen wie sie es
auch gesagt haben das eine laden kann
dass das andere land kann dass die täter
interessiert so was doch eigentlich gar
nicht und wenn man es ganz genau nimmt
finde ich eigentlich auch wenn das
utopisch ist sollten wir über eine art
digitale welt gesellschaft diskutieren
die im netz die verantwortung auch zum
kampf gegen kindesmissbrauch aufnimmt
und das mit
gemeinsam regeln mit gemeinsamen
strukturen und mit gemeinsamen
ermittlungsmethoden und kapazitäten
macht weil es gehört auch dazu wenn man
jetzt sagt 400.000 täter dass wir
darüber tara und tausende von terabyte
an informationen reden
die erst mal aus ermittelt werden müssen
so was kann ja eigentlich kaum ein kunde
oder ein land oder ein bundesland sogar
noch machen und nummer zum beispiel auch
dass man sich das vorstellen kann mac
mac eine internet also eine
kinderschutzorganisation in ruhe über
zum beispiel automatisch
kinderpornografische inhalte gemeldet
werden werden sie gefunden werden über
die sozialen medien haben in den letzten
bericht von 22 millionen dateien die
bekannt waren die bei ihnen hochgeladen
wurden berichtet bei facebook bei den
sozialen medien microsoft und so was die
das dann gemeldet haben 22 millionen und
das war nur in den usa stellen sie sich
vor was man da weltweit eigentlich
findet und wir agieren dann sehr
national strukturiert was trotzdem gut
ist besser als gar nicht aber ich glaube
tatsächlich wir der kollege oder wie
auch immer wieder das sagt wir brauchen
eine ganz andere präsenz im netz und
eine ganz andere methode um gegen diese
delikte vorzugehen und da darf man sich
jetzt nicht nur auf das dach wird
konzentrieren sondern es ist überall zu
finden
zum beispiel gibt es auch das thema web
cams sexy views das bedeutet dass zum
beispiel auch in deutschland ein täter
vor kurzem erst vor gericht gestanden
der über die webcam den missbrauch eines
kindes bezahlt und auf anweisung wird
dann das kind missbraucht nach seiner
anweisung das sind keine täter neben
david gross agieren das passiert über so
geschichten wie skype zum beispiel und
das ist mir immer ganz wichtig nicht nur
dass dort nicht sondern überall täter
sollten sich eigentlich nicht sicher
fühlen aber viele fühlen sich
anscheinend sicher dass sie sich sicher
fühlen das zeigt ja eben auch die
vielzahl der fälle denn sie machen dass
gerade deutlich wie schockieren das ist
400.000 mitglieder bei dieser plattform
beust auf der anderen seite aber eben
viele andere fälle auch gehabt es sind
ist es nicht dass der einzige fall
gerade in den vergangenen jahren haben
wir mehrere fälle gehabt blicken wir
kurz darauf und unterhalten uns dann
über die weiteren dinge weiter schauen
wir erstmal zusammengefasst was allein
an dingen in den vergangenen jahren
aufgedeckt worden sind
2017 wird die missbrauchs plattform
elysium zerschlagen auf hinweis von
australischen kollegen finden ermittler
im hessischen bad camberg 1 für das
darknet abgeschirmten server über 100
11.000 nutzerkonten tauschten bilder und
videos von teils schwerstem sexuellen
kindesmissbrauch aus vier deutsche
werden zu mehrjährigen haftstrafen
verurteilt
anfang 2018 löst der fall staufen
bundesweit entsetzen aus eine mutter und
ihr wegen kindesmissbrauchs
vorbestrafter partner missbrauchen ihren
sohn und bieten ihnen gegen geld im
internet an
sieben männer und die mutter werden zu
teils langjährigen haftstrafen
verurteilt
2009 10 wird der fall in lichte bei
bielefeld bekannt auf einem campingplatz
haben mehrere männer über jahre hinweg
kinder missbraucht und davon aufnahmen
angefertigt und verbreitet insgesamt
ging es um sexuellen kindesmissbrauch in
hunderten fällen eher zufällig bringt
eine hausdurchsuchung 2009 10 bei
schlüsselfigur jörg l den fall bergisch
gladbach und eine ermittlungslage ins
rollen
er hatte seine tochter 14 fach
missbraucht die gewalttaten mit anderen
in chat gruppen geteilt
seither wird bundesweit gegen hunderte
verdächtige ermittelt in münster haben
ermittler 2020 ein großes pädophilen
netz entdeckt hauptbeschuldigter it
techniker aus münster in einer
gartenlaube soll er mehrere kinder
missbraucht haben mittlerweile gibt es
über 40 verdächtige nicht zuletzt wegen
dieser fälle wird im märz das strafrecht
verschärft sexueller missbrauch und der
besitz oder die verbreitung von
kinderpornografie ist damit in jedem
fall als verbrechen einzustufen
mindeststrafe ein jahr
jetzt habe ich gerade noch mal gehört
münster möchte bergisch gladbach da sind
ja drei missbrauchs komplexe enormen
ausmaßes die in nordrhein westfalen seit
2009 10 entdeckt worden sind
tut sich viel in nordrhein westfalen
oder ist die polizei in
nordrhein-westfalen aktiver als woanders
auch wieder eine sehr gute frage und
wenn sie mich nach meiner einschätzung
fragen dann macht nrw eigentlich das was
alle machen sollten sie investieren
ressourcen weil offenbar heraus dass
frühzeitig jetzt verstanden hat dass das
ein riesenproblem ist und das ist aus
dem dunkelfeld herausgeholt werden muss
und dafür muss man ressourcen
investieren gibt sogar santl symptom für
das milchwerk syndrom das bedeutet wenn
du ressourcen polizei in solche räume
schicks dort wo die täter unterwegs sind
dann führt das nicht dazu dass du
weniger fälle kriegst sondern es führt
dazu dass du mehr fall zeigen kriegst
das du diese fall komplexe auflösung mit
jedem fall komplex wie auch in diesem
feld geschickt hast du verzweigungen zu
immer neuen tätern immer neuen
strukturen und eins muss man hierbei
auch noch mal klar sagen zum beispiel
auch bergisch gladbach gab es auch
hinweise auf 30.000 tatverdächtige oder
30.000 hinweise auf tatverdächtige
wir sind immer ähnlich große zahlen
und normalerweise schafft man es nicht
die natürlich alle herauszuholen weil
30.000 tatverdächtige 400.000 nutzer wie
mit welchen kapazitäten soll das
passieren das heißt eigentlich müssten
wir alle vielleicht sogar zentralisiert
diese ressourcen investieren und dann
werden sie noch viel mehr zahlen haben
da werden sie vielleicht jeden tag
solche komplexe haben das wird eine
schmerzhafte situation aber schmerzhaft
nur weil man sieht wie allgegenwärtig
das eigentlich sein kann was für einer
masse das stattfindet und das -
passieren da müssen die politiker die
innenpolitik muss sich dort
zusammenreißen und akzeptieren das mache
ich auch die fallzahlen steigen in den
kriminalstatistiken und das ist kann ich
mir vorstellen schmerzhaft aber es ist
wichtig aus dem dunkelfeld herausholen
ins elfte und dafür müssen ressourcen
bereitgestellt werden polizei lassen sie
jetzt im netz tausende von polizisten
nach sowas rund um die uhr suchen dann
werden sie ganz andere zahlen und
bekommen sie sprechen ist die masse an
zusagen gerade tausende von polizisten
ich lese jetzt hier die pressemitteilung
heute herausgegeben der justizministerin
in hessen eva kühne hörmann die also
sich sozusagen lobt und sagt 2020 hat
man ja bei der zentralstelle für
zentralstelle zur bekämpfung der
internet und computerkriminalität zehn
neue stellen geschaffen das sah ja prima
wenn sie jetzt sagen wie viele millionen
von dateien etc durchforstet werden
müssen reicht dann sowas aus wenn sie
mich fragen ich würde viel mehr
ressourcen versuchen zu investieren aber
ich habe natürlich auch leicht weil ich
die verantwortung nicht zu tragen habe
sondern ich diese ableitungen treffen
kann
eins muss man aber hier doch nochmal
klar sagen oder vielleicht mal eine
zusammenhängen ziehen
wir haben in den kriminalstatistiken in
der polizeilichen kriminalstatistik in
den letzten vier jahren eine tendenz auf
die sich so viele auch ausruhen und die
als gut darstellen dass nämlich die
fallzahlen der kriminalität in dieser
polizeilichen kriminalstatistik um knapp
16 prozent gesunken sind in den letzten
vier jahren eine million fallzahlen
weniger von 65 millionen auf 5,3
millionen obwohl werde steigende
bevölkerungszahl haben und für mich
immer ganz einfache erklärung die
menschen verbringen mehr zeit im netz
und weniger auf der straße und auf der
straße wird viel angezeigt weil er
nämlich die polizei in die
sicherheitsbehörden massen vorhanden
sind im netz sind sie es aber nicht dort
zeigt man kaum etwas an also es gibt
ganz viele studien darauf hinweisen dass
das anzeigeverhalten exorbitant
niedriger bei allen delikten mit
digitalen bezug sind und wenn man aber
jetzt 15 prozent 16 prozent weniger
pipeline haben da müssen doch ressourcen
frei
dann müssen noch ressourcen in einem
umfang frei werden die uns ermöglichen
müssten in das netz zu verlagern eine
million weniger fallzahlen das muss doch
sich irgendwie das spiegeln
schaut man aber genauer schauen wir uns
das ganz kurz grafisch an was sie
ansprechen und reden wir dann weiter
darüber denn das ist so ein bisschen
auch etwas wo der missbrauchsbeauftragte
der bundesregierung heute in einem
interview mit der rheinischen post
gesagt hat alarm
hunderttausende kinder werden gequält
gefoltert und das schlimme ist eben dass
die taten in diesem bereich erschreckend
gestiegen sind im vergleich zu anderen
sachen und hier ist die grafik die das
zeigt während die polizeiliche
kriminalstatistik 2020 im vierten jahr
in folge insgesamt weniger kriminalfälle
registriert gibt es immer mehr fälle von
verbreitung erwerb besitz und
herstellung kinderpornografischer
schriften 2018 gab 7449 2009 10 12 1262
und 2020 wurden 18 1761 fälle
registriert ein anstieg von 53 prozent
im vergleich zum vorjahr dieser wird
unter anderem im zusammenhang mit den
ermittlungen zu lichten
bergisch gladbach und münster gebracht
also noch mal die zahlen die herr röhrig
heute genannt hat und was sie eben
meinen es gibt weniger wohnungseinbrüche
weil wir wegen corona zu hause sind aber
es wird halt mehr im netz gesurft und
damit haben eben dann sozusagen täte
auch da die besseren möglichkeiten ja da
ist die frage geben warum wird nicht
mehr investiert von polizeilicher seite
übrigens schwieriger interviewpartner
warum ich würde sagen cyber grooming hat
sogar noch ein anstieg auch um 50
prozent im verhältnis zum vorjahr bei
der kinderpornografie an schicken muss
man aber fairerweise auch etwas zu sagen
nicht alles davon ist so wie sie sich
das vielleicht vorstellen schwerste
sexuelle missbrauch abbildung sondern
wir haben auch viel das phänomen dass an
schulen zb sobald ein 14 jähriger junge
von seiner 13 jährigen freundin ein
nacktbild bekommt das teilweise als
kinderpornografie gilt und aufgenommen
wird zb ist es so dass die anzahl der
kinder und jugendlichen tatverdächtigen
denselben zusammenhängen
von 20 prozent auf 40 prozent bei
kinderpornographie gestiegen sind hin
zum letzten jahr das sind fragen die wir
uns über medienkompetenz zum beispiel
noch unterhalten müssen weil es
eigentlich auch jeder zweite
tatverdächtige ist ein kind und
jugendlicher
das muss man differenzieren es gibt die
wie wir es heute drüber reden und es
gibt aber auch diese ampeln phänomene
die mit medienkompetenz zu tun haben
warum nicht verlagert wird
ja ich glaube es ist ein schmerzhafter
prozess weil aus meiner sicht immer
automatisch auch einhergehen wird mit
einem gewissen einflussverlust in der
politik weil man muss ich ehrlich sagen
wir haben diesen globalen raum sie
werden noch nie eine landesgrenze
nordrhein westfalen im netz gestellt
haben baden württemberg deutschland
österreich eigentlich müssten wir unsere
aufgaben unsere maßnahmen zentrieren
müssten zentral dass steuern mehr
polizei vielleicht auch abgeben der
länder hin zu einer bunt
verantwortlichkeit die gezielt im netz
nach solchen delikten sucht rund um die
uhr versucht täter zu überführen in
allen sozialen medien im damit und das
würde aber bedeuten dass man halt auch
einfluss der länder glaube ich wegnimmt
und gleichzeitig würde es dazu führen
dass die kriminalstatistiken wieder
steigen würden und zwar gesamt nicht nur
weil kinderpornografie sondern es werden
so viele delikte dass die
kriminalstatistiken steigen und ich
haben das heißt eben auch ein bisschen
nach dem motto auch wenn man da jetzt zu
sehr intensiv buddeln und schauen
enteignet oder auch im kleinen dass die
schilder statistik
da gibt's die präventivwirkung des
nichtwissens vom puls der sagt manchmal
also kein rechtsstaat mehr in der lage
das gesamte sind ungefährt abzuarbeiten
und hier sehen wir diese ansätze und
deswegen müssten wir eigentlich von
sachen wo wir ressourcen frei haben oder
wie diese vielleicht nicht ganz so
wichtig sind müsste uns die gesellschaft
eigentlich die möglichkeiten einräumen
dass ins netz zu verlagern
beispielsweise vielleicht manche delikte
nicht mehr so voll verfolgen müssen über
das legalitätsprinzip sondern sagen dann
gucken wir uns doch mal die schweren
delikte an dann machen wir doch im netz
die streifen geben wir aktiver rein
jahren steigen die fallzahlen aber was
soll's dann setzen wir uns als politik
hin und sagen wir haben steigende
fallzahlen aber doch nur weil wir es
schaffen die täter herauszuholen und
intensiv dagegen vorzugehen und da
braucht man ein bisschen ja vielleicht
ist es hilft es sozusagen mehr mumm zu
verbreiten zu motivieren
lob für ermittler von pat shortt über
facebook der sagt vor diesen ermittlern
muss man einen hut ziehen sie sehen
jeden tag die menschlichen abgründe mehr
noch sie gehen da rein und holen die
kinder daraus davon muss man seinen hut
ziehen also seine motivation an die
politik es ist wirklich was gutes und
würde vielleicht auch belohnt wenn man
dort aktiver wäre die andere frage die
sich natürlich automatisch stellt wenn
man den ermittlungsdruck erhöht ist klar
das ist das eine wie sieht es aber aus
mit strafen
jetzt hat man ja nun im märz das
strafrecht verschärft das ganze noch
erhöht also auch die verbreitung der
besitz kinderpornografischen materials
ist also schlicht auf jeden fall ein
verbrechen
jetzt schreibt wohl im sch m muss ich
einfach so vorlesen wie es hier steht
über facebook was nützt das alles denn
wenn die täter nicht eine gerechte
strafe bekommen wenn täter mit
geldstrafe oder bewährung davonkommen
die kinder sind gefangen in ihrem
schmerz ein lebenslang und wie sieht das
denn aus mit der strafe wie sehen sie
das denn
also ich habe da zwei sichtweisen einmal
als kriminologe kann ich sie in
wissenschaftlicher kern und einmal bin
ich selber familienvater und haben auch
subjektiv geprägt das gebe ich auch ganz
offen zu als kriminologe muss ich ihnen
sagen wir wissen dass die strafhöhe
normalerweise keinen einfluss darauf hat
ob ein täter handelt also man darf sich
nicht jetzt hier irgendwie erzählen ich
erhöhe die strafen und damit kann ich es
jetzt schaffen den kindesmissbrauch zu
bekämpfen das ist nicht der sinn der
sache
das wird auch nicht passieren dafür
müssen wir den strafverfolgungsbehörden
besprochen haben ressourcen verlagern
mehr polizei technische einrichtungen
geld investieren und das ist vermutlich
einfacher dann zu sagen wir machen die
strafen als familienvater und ich
persönlich wenn sie mich fragen dann
zeigt es auch die wertigkeit einer
gesellschaft wie schwer solche delikte
bestraft werden auch den opfern
gegenüber
und da muss ich ehrlich sagen ja dann
bin ich auch einer der sagt das kann
sollte nicht allzu niedrig bestraft
werden in dieser form aber das ist sehr
subjektiv als wissenschaftler sage ich
ihnen die straff rahmen hat vermutlich
keine keine große rolle es sei denn der
straff druck ist schon so hoch dass es
dann vielleicht eine bedeutung machen
man muss aber auch ein sphäre noch weise
noch zu sagen und zwar dieser absolute
strafbarkeit des verbrechens tatbestand
ist die halte ich für nicht so gut weil
ich habe ja auch schon gesagt dass knapp
die hälfte ungefähr mittlerweile kinder
und jugendliche selber tatverdächtige
sind die diese bilder zum beispiel indem
whatsapp klassen chat einmalposten und
alle die das mit runterladen machen sich
automatisch strafbar und jetzt wegen dem
verbrechen
das ist das ist eine komplizierte
geschichte ich würde gerne das wir haben
dass wir noch mal neu differenzieren
zwischen kinderpornografie weil wenn sie
kinderpornografie sagen
kinderpornografische inhalte
denken sie an so was wie dieses böse
bauzaun schwere missbrauchsdelikte und
sie denken nicht zum beispiel vermutlich
an die bilder die freiwillig konstruiert
worden das hat auch noch nie der
gesetzgeber gedacht dass es mal
situationen gibt wo ein kind von sich
für ein anderes kind oder für die
jugendlichen selber solche bilder
anfertigt aber das gibt es mittlerweile
rauf und runter an schulen deswegen
dieser massive anstieg bei kindern und
jugendlichen als tatverdächtigen danke
schonmal ganz ganz herzlich für die
einschätzungen ein bisschen der
scheinwerfer auf die ermittlungen auf
die umstände gerichtet vielen dank dr
rüdiger und wir wollen nämlich jetzt ein
bisschen weiter sprechen über das thema
eben was sind das für täter was sind es
für kinder mit astrid helling buckley
von der world childhood foundation noch
mal vielen dank dass sie mit dabei sind
das gespräch haben sie jetzt verfolgt
das stellt sich automatisch die frage
wenn wir von einem doktor rüdiger eben
hören es ist schwierig höhere strafen
werden das verhalten nicht großartig
ändern
die polizei müsste mehr tun
nordrhein-westfalen vielleicht als
vorreiter so ein bisschen genommen
werden
dann stellt sich aber doch irgendwie die
frage was sind denn das eigentlich für
täter und am ende wie können wir unsere
kinder schützen fangen wir einfach mal
mit den tätern an aus welchem umfeld
kommen denn solche menschen die kinder
sexuell missbrauchen bilder ins netz
stellen und damit für sehr viel leid und
elend sorgen
ich denke wir müssen wirklich anfangen
damit dass das das mögliche nahfeld
kinder
in den allermeisten fällen von
sexualisierter gewalt passiert das im
direkten umfeld von vertrauenspersonen
von familie zum bekannten von
überwiegend männern in dem bereich aber
auch von frauen dafür machen wir auch
die augen zu und das im direkten umfeld
in dem bereich in dem die betroffenen
diese personen kennen in eine
abhängigkeit stehen auch in eventuell
einer positiven beziehung nämlich dass
sie diese menschen mögen ihnen vertrauen
wie die eigenen eltern zum beispiel und
das macht die ganze sache noch viel viel
schwieriger denn letztendlich ein kind
das sich offenbaren möchte überlegt sich
was wem sage ich dass wer glaubt mir
habe ich was falsch gemacht oder es war
eine strafe die ich verdient habe und
das macht es so unglaublich schwierig
für die betroffenen dass das wirklich
genau dieses nahe umfeld ist es ist
nicht der fremde der auf der straße
anspricht
also es ist beispielsweise im
sportverein wenn es der trainer ist dann
hat das kind ja ein gewisses vertrauen
zu dem trainer martin auch möchte
vielleicht ja nicht von dem sportclub
ausgeschlossen werden befürchtet dann
diese dinge und damit ist dieses
sozusagen diese nahe beziehung dann ein
problem wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
genau und umso näher eigentlich umso
mehr was ist wenn es die eigene familie
ist was ist wenn es der onkel ist dann
heißt sich offenbar im zweifelsfall die
gesamte familie kaputt machen was können
wir denn jetzt tun wie können wir denn
beispielsweise überhaupt erkennen wer
ist opfer sexuellen missbrauchs welches
kind ist opfer sexualisierter gewalt
geworden gibt es da irgendwelche
erkennungszeichen sie sagen ja gerade
das problem ist dass das kind jetzt im
in den seltensten fällen offen darüber
spricht weil der trainer ja sagt hier du
verletzt aber nicht etc
weil ja sozusagen die freundschaftliche
autorität genutzt wird wie können wir
denn jetzt aber irgendwelche anzeichen
erkennen
letztendlich geht es darum die kinder
genau anzugucken und ihnen zuzuhören
denn oft sieht man optisch gar nichts
man sieht nicht dass die kinder
irgendwie nur heulen oder nicht mehr
sprechen oder dass die wunden oder
verletzungen haben oder so etwas das ist
gar nicht im vordergrund sondern dass
sie vielleicht etwas zurückgezogener
sind dass sie vielleicht angst vor
sachen haben vielleicht haben sie auch
alpträume mal gehabt aber erzählen es
niemand
es geht wirklich darum dass die menschen
die nah an den kindern dran sind das
heißt auch wirklich die neuen
bezugspersonen die schützend sein können
auch die kindergärten auch die schulen
letztendlich sehr genau gucken müssen
wie geht es unseren kindern wir fühlen
die sich ist vielleicht einfach mal die
situation gegeben dass man sagt hey wie
gehts dir ist alles in ordnung bei dir
magst du mir was erzählen und dann aber
auch wirklich zu hören
jetzt schreiben unsere userinnen und
user das problem fängt ja teilweise auch
schon auf den öffentlichen seite nebenan
wenn die eltern ihre kinder vor kameras
präsentieren in ihre stories auf
instagram sieht man auch immer wieder
dass dann das kind mal mit aufs foto
geholt wird fängt das da auch schon ein
bisschen an dass man da ein bisschen
kritisch mit umgehen müsste und sich
fragen selbst fragen müsste was machen
da manche eltern mit sicherheit also das
ist auch was der kollegen angesprochen
hat medienkompetenz
wie gehe ich mit meinen eigenen bildern
um von wem lerne ich das denn im zweifel
zwar nicht das von meinen eltern die es
auch schon machen oder von meinen
freunden wie kann ich mich schützen
wir bringen jedem kind einen helm und
ziehen soll dass es irgendwie im
straßenverkehr nicht bei rot über die
ampel läuft aber wir erzählen ihm nicht
wie es sich sicher im internet bewegen
kann was es da machen kann um hilfe zu
suchen um sich zu schützen oder auch
vielleicht um ein dorf aufmerksam zu
machen wenn was nicht in ordnung ist
genauso müssen wir das unseren kindern
von vornherein beibringen und in den
raum geben darüber zu sprechen
sie können nur sich mitteilen wenn etwas
komisches passiert oder sie sachen
erleben oder nicht mehr weiter wissen
wie sie mit etwas umgehen wenn sie das
gefühl haben mit menschen darüber
sprechen zu können
ich habe jetzt einfach mal auf was
kerstin römer über youtube schreibt ich
habe angst sagt sie mein kind auf das
www also das internet loszulassen ist
überhaupt noch irgendetwas annähernd
sicher wo kinder in kontakt treten
können traurig und sehr schlimm sagt sie
wenn wir jetzt alles das man zusammen
nehmen auch das was dr rüdiger gesagt
hat muss man ja einfach sagen es ist wie
den kopf einer medusa abschlagen eine
plattform ist geschlossen
vernichtet oder aus dem verkehr gezogen
dann entstehen zwei drei neue also kann
man ja wahrscheinlich ausschließen dass
es irgendwann den tag wo es keine täter
geben wird die im netz versuchen an
kinder ran zu kommen kontakte
herzustellen
also würde ich ja sagen stellt sich dann
eben für uns als eltern die frage wie
kann man das kind stark machen wenn ich
das ja auch richtig verstehe
um eben nein zu sagen cara münchen song
schreibt über facebook kinder können nur
durch richtige und frühzeitige
aufklärung geschützt werden erklären sie
einfach mal wie kann man denn kinder
stark machen dass sie sage ich mal nein
sagen
also ich denke ganz einfach mit sachen
anfangen die wir auch im offline machen
würden redest du mit fremden oder
vertraute fremden muss sehr vorsichtig
sein man geht nicht mit fremden mit man
spricht auch einfach im internet mich
nicht mit irgendwelchen fremden vertraut
ihnen bilder an oder sachen oder geheime
geschichten die gegebenenfalls wieder
zur erpressung führen könnten zum
beispiel das sind ganz einfache sachen
mit denen man anfangen kann und auch den
kindern klar zu machen wenn was passiert
womit du dich nicht wohl fühlst also
jemand sagt etwas zu dir jemand fasst
sich an jetzt offline gesehen oder
jemand erpresst ich oder möchte dich
unter druck setzen oder die ich mit
etwas locken dann musst du dir überlegen
warum man das tut und wenn das etwas ist
womit du dich nicht wohl fühlst dann
rede mit jemandem darüber mit dem du
darüber reden kannst du dir zu hören
kann und soll und das zins eltern
freunde schule kindergarten all diese
bereiche und damit kann man allein schon
anfangen
natürlich gibt es auch sicherheits
einstellungen die man mit den kindern
durchgehen kann die kleinen brauchen
viel schutz den man ihnen einstellt aber
gerade auch die jugendlichen die
sozusagen auch dann in dem raum sich
frei bewegen im world wide web denen
muss man auch wege aufzeigen wie sie
sich selber schützen können ein
jugendlicher weiß auch dass er sich beim
fahrradfahren den helm aufsetzen muss
oder beim autofahren anstellen soll und
möchte auch nicht irgendwie bei einem
unfall verunglücken
genauso kann man denen auch helfen wie
sie sich selber selbstständig aber mit
schutzmaßnahmen im netz bewegen und
diese mittel gibt es denn das netz ist
auch positiv was das angeht es macht ja
viel möglich und es gibt auch den
kindern und jugendlichen neue
kompetenzen
die sind viel offener was das angeht und
auch viel fähiger in vielen dank
hinsicht als erwachsene und vielleicht
müssen wir erwachsenen uns eher
überlegen wie können wir die kinder auf
diesem weg begleiten und sie sich selber
besser helfen lassen also wachsamer sein
mit den kindern sprechen die ganze sache
ernst nehmen aber erklären sie
normalerweise sagen erpressen auf der
anderen seite ist es ja sozusagen zu
köchen etwas locken
aber haben sie einfach mal konkrete
beispiele wenn sie sagen kinder werden
unter druck gesetzt zum beispiel fängt
es wirklich an mit solchen bildmaterial
ist es natürlich dass kinder auch bilder
von sich selber ins netz stellen die
bewegen sich in den sozialen medien
aber da ist dann vielleicht auch jemand
der das aus nutzt das mag in derselben
altersgruppe sein das haben wir gehört
die zahlen nehmen zu aber es kann
genauso gut auch ein erwachsener sein
der sich in einen chat mit
eingeschlichen hat und dann über das
bild erpresst oder sagt ich leite das an
deine eltern weiter oder ich bedrohe
deine eltern oder deine freunde
ich weiß wo du dich bewegst ich weiß wo
du nachmittags bist als solche sachen
sind ja möglich und das ist etwas was
gar nicht so erwartet wird oder wo man
gar nicht mit intention etwas gemacht
hat oder so ein bild reingestellt hat
aber dann ist es da und dann wird man
damit erpresst und dann wird etwas
anderes eingefordert wenn man das nicht
macht dann kommt wieder was neues dran
und es gibt eine immer wiederkehrende
schleife und wenn man sich nicht weiß
wie man an so einer stelle sich helfen
kann oder wo jemand ist der einem helfen
kann dann kommt man auch erstmal nicht
so schnell auf so was wieder raus also
sind mehrere sachen dass man sozusagen
kinder aufklärt was die gefahren des
internets sind da sollten wir vielleicht
auch gar keine scheu haben mit den
kindern darüber zu sprechen weil sie
vielleicht viel weiter sind als wir
denken
das haben sie sehr schön deutlich
gemacht auf der anderen seite haben sie
ja ganz am anfang auch gesagt dass man
die kinder motiviert über alles zu
sprechen denn es natürlich aber ihnen
raus ist ja auch ein gewisses problem
wenn eine vertrauensperson ich sag mal
der trainer vom fußballverein jemanden
erpresst und sagte hier ich gehe dahin
der eltern vor wenn du mir wenn du das
verrät dass ich hier ein foto von dir
gemacht habe
und insofern möchte man vielleicht aus
zweierlei gründen als kind dann die
eltern nicht gefährden und den trainer
auch nicht irgendwie bloßstellen etc
also da hilft ja nur dieses motivieren
das dass das kind dann doch über diese
dinge redet richtig genau und auch
natürlich aufklären dass solche sachen
passieren können
es ist utopisch zu glauben dass ein kind
nicht irgendwann erlebt was erpressung
ist oder was bedrohung ist das ist ja
wie soll ich sagen
das erfahren wir alle irgendwann wenn
wir groß werden und gerade aber auch
über solche sachen zu sprechen und wie
man sich dann auch helfen kann sie sich
selber helfen können oder auch wer ihnen
helfen kann
das sind ganz wichtige sache aber noch
viel wichtiger ist auch wirklich
zuzuhören an diesen stellen
wir haben jetzt von diesen riesengroßen
fällen gesprochen es ist lange bekannt
dass durchschnittlich in deutschland in
einer schulklasse ein bis zwei kinder
von sexueller gewalt betroffen sind die
sind alle um uns herum das sind nicht
die einzelnen fälle die dann ins netz
gestellt wurden oder irgend eine groß
angelegte kommerzielle vergewaltigung
sage ich mal szenerie die da geschaffen
wurde
diese formen von gewalt passieren um uns
herum das was hinzugekommen ist in den
letzten jahren und den letzten jahrzehnt
vor allem ist dass diese verbreitung die
nutzung und auch die sage ich mal
anbahnung durch das netz noch mal
deutlich deutlich zugenommen hat aber
passieren tut hat die ganze zeit um uns
herum
jetzt schreibt nadine sabbat oder selber
ich weiß nicht über facebook oft sitzen
sie haben es ja selbst schon
angesprochen als wir gesprochen haben
über die täter ist ist nicht der fremde
oder der ganz weit entfernt ist er hat
sie rechner dienen schreibt aber oft
sitzen die täter ja zu hause mit am
tisch wir haben ja fälle gehabt wo es
der stiefvater ist die mutter das ganze
zugelassen hat wenn wir uns an münster
zum beispiel erinnern welche wege zeigt
man den diesen kindern auf sich zu
schützen
letztendlich müssen wir von außen auch
in den bereichen anfangen wo diese
kinder gesehen werden und das ist
wirklich ganz bezahlt von der
kindertagesstätte von dem verein das
sind ja auch schützende faktoren das
sind nicht die orte wo es primär immer
passieren muss sondern auch die orte wo
sich ein kind anvertrauen kann
das heißt gerade die kinder die sage ich
mal zu hause kein stabiles umfeld haben
die vielleicht auch hochgradig risiken
ausgesetzt werden weil schon in der
familie sexuelle gewalt oder körperliche
gewalt etwas ist was generell vor
herrscht in erziehung auch zum beispiel
dass man auf diese kinder halt versucht
auch in den anderen bereichen
einzuwirken dass man auch als
kindergärtnerin geschult ist dass man
als
lehrer geschult ist damit umzugehen dass
man als nachbar zuhört wenn das kind zum
spielen rüberkommt und das sind wirklich
ganz wesentliche sachen denn diese
kinder haben sonst gar keine chance
es gibt auch im netz angeboten das heißt
wenn die kinder älter werden und dann
auch selber wieder kompetenzen im netz
haben ist es auch eine schutzmöglichkeit
dass sie nämlich aus einem sehr
abgeschotteten privaten raum vielleicht
über solche medien sogar im online raum
hilfe und schutz finden können was das
angeht
aber da müssen wir wirklich ganz von
anfang an als gesellschaft anfangen zu
sagen diese kinder leben alle in unserer
gesellschaft es gibt welche die haben
höhere risiken betroffen zu sein auch
gerade kinder mit eigentlichen
einschränkungen auch grad kognitiver art
die einfach einfacher opfer sind muss
man sagen dass wir genau auf die auch
wirklich bewusst schauen und aber
generell allen kindern diese wege
ermöglichen wie gesagt das ist wirklich
so diese sitzen in allen schulklassen in
allen kindergärten und sind immer mit
jüngere kinder und wenn man dann eben
anzeichen erkennt dann sollte man eben
handeln es gibt auch das ist vielleicht
gerichte der richtige zeitpunkt mal die
nummer einzublenden ein hilfs telefon
bei sexuellem missbrauch die wollen wir
einfach auch mal zeigen und sie können
ja sagen ob das eine gute idee ist ob es
andere möglichkeiten gibt sie haben auch
gesagt im internet gibt es ja eben auch
verschiedene möglichkeiten wenn ich sie
jetzt richtig verstehe kümmern sie sich
ja eben bei world childhood foundation
bei der stiftung also auch darum sie
haben wir aber im vorgespräch erklärt es
geht auch in einer art und weise um eine
sekundäre prävention wenn man jetzt über
die eigentliche prävention gesprochen
wie können wir kinder stark machen was
können wir tun wie können wir dinge auch
eben entdecken eine sekundäre prävention
der meinen sie mit wenn fälle vor
gericht landen dass es dann nicht noch
einmal zu einer zweiten tragödie fürs
kind kommt ne richtig
man muss sich bewusst machen von all
diesen fällen die draußen passieren
kommenden eine straff ermittlung oder
auch an den jugendämtern nur ein paar
prozent an das ist dieses so bekannte
dunkelfeld und das bisschen was im
hellfeld ankommt aber wenn diese kinder
dann irgendwo auftauchen in den systemen
bei einer kindeswohlgefährdung meldung
oder auch bei einer straff ermittlung
was passiert dann plötzlich sind wieder
erwachsene da die mit den kindern
brechen immer wieder befragen rät
traumatisieren sie plötzlich zigtausend
fremden menschen ausgeliefert sind an
fünf stellen müssen ein verfahren von
zwei jahren vor sich haben wohin jemand
sagt du darfst jetzt aber nicht mit
einem psychotherapeuten reden weil wir
erst mal das verfahren abschließen
wollen das sind formen der sekundären
traumatisierung die dann folgen nach
diesen eigentlichen taten und es gibt
auch solche kommentare auch wenn sie
sich das angucken von betroffenen beim
die berichten die sagen hätte ich
gewusst was danach passiert in dieser
ganzen verfahren und prozessen und
aufarbeitung
es war so schlimm ich hätte lieber nie
was gesagt das andere war nicht so
schlimm wie das was dann folgte und wenn
man sich das klarmacht dass das was wir
danach in den verfahren diesen jungen
menschen zumuten ohne auf ihre
bedürfnisse auf ihre probleme und auf
ihre altersgerechte entwicklung
einzugehen
das kann man sich kaum vorstellen
überlegen sie sich mal wie es für einen
erwachsenen ist in einem polizeirevier
befragt zu werden oder in ein gericht
herein zu gehen jetzt überlegen sie mal
ein kind es 11 das kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen
und es gibt möglichkeiten darauf zu
reagieren und genau dort eine
kindgerechte altersgerechte auch
betreuung beratung und verfahrensführung
zu machen aber das ist kein standard in
deutschland weiß gott nicht
und da setzen sie sich eben für ein dass
da sich einiges verbessert dass sich da
einiges ändert letzter punkt sie haben
mal gesprochen von täter prävention und
dr rüdiger sagte auch das ist ja
durchaus interessant dass es eben nicht
nur
der 56 jährige ist der eine achtjährige
dazu bringt nacktbilder von sich machen
zu lassen und die dann ins internet ins
darknet oder klinik stellt nein es sind
auch jugendliche und kinder
untereinander die fotos voneinander
machen und das verteilen was wie sieht
es da aus
es ist ein ganz wichtiger schritt zu
sagen was man lange vernachlässigt hat
wir werden dann überhaupt irgendwann
täter
und was passiert um eine tat nicht zu
wiederholen und diese maßnahmen das
heißt vorzubeugen auch diese
verhaltensweisen möglichst
dagegenzusteuern frühzeitig da
therapeutisch an
zugreifen und auch wirklich
möglichkeiten offen zu halten dass es
sich nicht weiter in diese richtung
entwickelt ist ganz ganz wichtig und
dafür gibt es ganz wenig angebot und
auch ganz wenige therapiemaßnahmen die
solchen leuten helfen und es ist nicht
nur das foto was ein jugendlicher
reinstellt ich kann ihnen aus meiner
jahrelangen erfahrung im kinderschutz
sagen es sind auch schwerste formen von
übergriffen sexualisierter gewalt die
schon innerhalb der zielgruppe im
gleichen alter passieren
und gerade da muss man ansetzen denn im
zweifel 2 ist das etwas was sich
fortsetzt wenn die grenzen nicht klar
sind wenn auch nicht die konsequenzen
klassen was das bedeutet dann geht es
halt weiter und da müssen wir auch
ansetzen sonst sind sozusagen die jungen
jugendlichen täter dann eben auch die
täter eines tages die dann die
erwachsenen sind wir bekommen da habe
ich ihnen erst mal sagen frau doktor
halligan baki ganz ganz viel feedback
lob für die arbeit ihrer stiftung aus
der community beispiel julia re aus
schreibt über facebook shalltoot
deutschland world childhood foundation
deutschland leistet da eine echt tolle
arbeit und wenn andere fragen wie zum
beispiel simon kühn über facebook was
kann man als nachbarin tun wenn man
etwas mitbekommt dann haben wir es
gerade gesagt einfach zb das hilfs
telefon bei sexuellem missbrauch werden
sich an sie beispielsweise wenden wir
haben auch noch weitere informationen
adressen kontakte dann bei uns eben netz
insofern lohnt es sich da auch noch mal
reinzuschauen ganz ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre hinweise erklärungen
erläuterungen die hoffentlich helfen
wir haben ja mitbekommen es gibt halt
viele fragen das beschäftigt viele leute
und das lob zeigt dass die arbeit glaube
ich nicht umsonst ist und zumindest
haben wir das mitbekommen eine sehr sehr
wichtige arbeit ist vielen dank frau dr
heiligen barke viele grüße und für den
abend auch vielen dank so und an sie
auch noch mal der hinweis wie gesagt
informationen kontakte bei uns im netz
einfach schauen klicken und dann können
sie vielleicht auch helfen jedenfalls
ist das
es gehört besser als nichts ein solches
netz im darknet zu zerschlagen auch wenn
man leider realistisch sagen muss das
ist nicht das ende es wird weitergehen
aus dem grund ist es eben auch wichtig
gewesen dass wir darüber sprechen was
können wir denn tun um kinder zu
schützen wenn es eine illusion ist oder
wäre zu glauben dass es in zukunft keine
täter mehr geben wird vielen vielen dank
für ihr interesse
tschüss und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]